hello everyone and welcome to today's
gitco galaxy tour webinar on developing
better techniques for 3d culture and
analysis
my name is marie stone and i'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational seminar is presented by lab
roots and brought to you by gibco by
thermo fisher scientific
this seminar is part of the gibco galaxy
tour 2021 webinar series designed to
help scientists master their cell
culture basics and learn more about
advanced 3d cell model techniques and
applications
there will also be a q a session towards
the end where our technical experts will
address your questions
i am pleased to introduce our two
speakers for today
dr edwin golez field application
scientist of thermo fisher scientific
has over 20 years of experience working
in the san diego biotech and pharmaceum
as a bench scientist
leveraging his experience in 3d human
tissues for model development and drug
toxicity screening
he will kick-start the seminar by
sharing about the 3d cell model
applications and workflows that thermo
fisher scientific has generated in-house
our second speaker dr bhasker mandavui
is the senior staff scientist of therma
fisher scientific who currently oversees
the development of fluorescent probes
for imaging and flow cytometry
applications
with over 15 years of experience
specializing in high content imaging and
development of fluorescent reagents
across technology platforms
he will be covering the essential tools
for labeling and detection in 3d models
let us welcome dr edwin golis to start
his presentation
uh thank you for that introduction
yeah again my name is edwin golis the
field application scientist here at
thermo fisher uh covering north america
and today we're going to talk about
3d models developing better techniques
for culture and analysis
so here's the agenda for my portion of
the talk first go into some background
on what 3d cell models are and then
we'll go into what is needed to create
these 3d models by highlighting the
thermo fisher 3d cell model portfolio
offering
to highlight these products we're going
to go over some 3d somewhat applications
some different workflows that we
that we support here at thermo fisher
and finally we'll end with resources and
a summary of our talk before we move on
to vascar's portion of the presentation
all right so
why do we want to create 3d models one
have an in vitro approach to predict
human biology
when we want a prediction in biology
means a way to mimic what we see in the
human body by looking at different types
of inputs that the body
that the body takes in such as a genetic
component environment or drugs and have
a way to measure these changes to the
input by looking at things as symptoms
biomarkers or outcomes
we create a cell model to
to hopefully capture that type of
complexity but we'll look at more
simplified
different inputs such as over expression
of gene or proteins
looking at media systems to mimic the
nutrition as well as the exposure to
drugs and measure comparable outputs to
see how those changes in inputs can
affect the system
so we're creating
cell models to better predict and
translate uh to predict outputs that
best translate to humans
kind of going into some definitions of
what we consider a 3d model uh photolite
all has a really nice uh definition
of a textbook definition is what we
consider uh what a 3d cell model is he
describes it as an in vitro a cellular
cluster from a particular cell source
which is capable of self-renewal and
organizing it has some sort of
similarity to the tissue of origin
the graph here on the right here
highlights different types of cell
models going from least complex
more simpler models on the left to more
complex more human and viva like on the
right uh starting on the left here with
the monolayer and for two-dimensional
cultures it's really your cells grown in
uh you know a culture dish or flask uh
use single cell uh this a single cell uh
method it's been used uh it's really
your
your drugs first exposure to a living
system so it's been used for several
years uh it's been uh can be used to
look at like early stage or
mechanism action functionality and also
toxic toxicity effects
as we move towards the middle as we
increase complexity we can uh
add multiple cell types to a uh to a 2d
model by looking at the co cultures
which will employ multiple cell types
two or more to see how that interaction
better mimics the unvivo system
another method that's used is the organ
on a chip modalities which
utilize a microfluidic device where you
have cells placed in these microfluidic
channels and you see the uh the effects
the flow and perfusion of media and drug
have on the system something you'd see
in the in vivo setting
the monolayer culture i made earlier is
usually used with uh immortalized cell
lines but to add complexity you can also
use uh primary cells or cells that are
procured freshly from uh from tissues
again to get that more individual-like
environment
but what we we're going to we just focus
on here at thermo fishing what i support
uh are the creation of 3d models uh
for for better mimicking in vivo
environment and those can be the
self-aggregating models such as
spheroids or organoids or also we can
support
other types of 3d models such as what
you would produce from a bioprint
kind of deep deeper diving into spheres
and organoids sometimes those
we like to kind of like to kind of
clarify between the two so spheroids uh
if we go with the fatula definition is a
cellular cluster but it's derived from
immortalized cell lines or primary uh
are primary cells
which may grow and proliferate depending
on the cell type uh and but they do not
change or differentiate into a different
cell type at the end of the
spheroid protocol so the cells that you
start with at the beginning of the
spheroid protocol will be the same type
of cells you have at the end
organoids on the other hand will come
from a stem cell source whether it's
whether it's embryonic stem cells uh
induced pluripotent or
adult derived again they grow and
proliferate uh but they will
change renew organize into a different
cell type or cell types at the end of
the uh the protocol so the cells you
start with at the beginning will be
different for what you have at the end
of the of the protocol
so why do researchers go into 3d models
this table here kind of goes into the
sort of the pros and cons of
transitioning from 2d to 3d i say the
biggest
advantage of going into 3d models is the
more representative morphology and our
cells do not grow in a
single layer
on a plastic dish uh you know the line
nicely next to each other they're grown
on top of each other through each other
with different proteins and components
growing through them uh which is really
more representative what you'd see in
the body
with that proper morphology
the cells are exposed to the uh to the
nutrients in a more proper way they're
also uh exposed to the drug and their
sensitivity of the drug is more
representative because they're grown in
the proper morphology
while those are benefits to having a 3d
system is that more in a vehicle-like
environment there's certain things you
need to consider uh before going into it
as you know these are it's a new system
that
it's a new type of system that people
may be going into so first is that
they're a newer it's a newer model as
opposed to 2d mods which have been
around for several decades there's not
that many uh validated uh or uh
or guided workflows for for 3d models as
there are for 2d models i think the data
is being gathered to generate those but
we're not that point where we can say
this one method is the correct way to do
this type of 3d model
uh they're a bit more complex compared
to 2d more components more
more different types of reagents or
plastics may have to be used which can
al which also impart a longer uh time to
create the models uh is going from uh a
magnitude of days for 2d systems to
several weeks or months to uh in 3d
systems which can also impart more of a
cost in terms of materials uh you know
work worker time uh media growth factors
to create a 3d system so these are some
considerations you need to
to look at before uh transitioning to a
3d model
but
what we like though with 3d models is
that you know they're more
physiologically relevant they provide an
access to human tissues and i think they
provide better approximation to what
you'll see in the body compared to 2d
so you know
we get asked you know quite a bit like
what do i need to get started to create
3d models and uh we
at thermometer we have a pretty broad
quite a broad offering that can support
you with many parts of the workflow
so uh
the 3d workflow of the week that we that
we supported can support you from
creating the model uh characterizing and
also imaging and analyzing it and for
the model creation uh it can be broken
down into three more points uh your cell
source how you're going to create the
model with the with your matrices or
culture vessels as well as the media
supplements as well and you'll see with
the with the cell portion we have a a
variety of primary cells in the stem
cells for your to develop different
spheroid or organoid cultures
depending on how you're going to make
your model whether you're going to use a
scaffold or accelerator matrix we have
different offerings for that as well as
for non-scaffold-based methods
non-matrix based we have specialized
plastics to help with your 3d model
creation
also with that we have different types
of median supplements many of which you
probably use for your 2d culture they
can translate over into your developing
3d model
and
you know you need to verify that the
model that you're that you're you've
taken the time
and expense to create again they take a
bit longer if you're taking all that
time you want to make sure your model is
physiologically relevant so we have a
lot of assays and reagents many of which
that vascular will talk about in his in
his portion to verify that you know your
your model is functional and is also
healthy uh in terms of uh
creating a model after all that time
with that we also have the
instrumentation to be able to uh analyze
this characterization whether it's uh
plate based such as uh our
plate-based readers these are various
scan lux or our image based systems such
as our evos or our cell and site h high
content screening platforms uh we can
also look at gene expression utilizing
our quant studio pcr instruments uh for
different types of
characterization analysis as well
finally another offering that we have
here is that we just launched is our 3d
cell bioservices which can
be a tool for the lab that may not have
the manpower to uh to develop these
systems we'll take that burden off you
and we can do different types of assay
development look at drug screening and
look at it look at your model through
multiple assay readouts so this is
really a snapshot of what we support at
thermo fisher for uh 3d uh 3d cell
models and as
we go to the next portion where i talk
about different workflows and kind of
highlight these products in
in action by talking about a particular
application
so the first one i want to highlight
here is our neural organoid uh workflow
uh here we have an application note uh
that is available online and it goes
into creating neural organoids from the
different differentiating uh induced
pluripotent stem cells so this
method here highlights
our cell offering our ipscs our matrices
our gel tricks in terms of to
differentiate and
create the organoids as well as our
media offering to grow and develop it
the biome uh autographer walks you
through the workflow starting with your
cells in 2d psc culture you'll harvest
them and place them into ultra low
attachment uh sphere plates to help form
embroidery bodies which are basically
psc spheroids this is where the clock
starts in terms of the timing uh we'll
have cells
form those uh those cell aggregates and
then we'll change the meter to an
induction media which allows them to
guide them towards the neural pathway
after that we will go into the word sort
of the magic happens where the uh the
paradigm where we will encapsulate the
uh the induced the embryo body with our
geltrex matrix to start the
differentiation spatial organization and
formation of that neural organoid and
then for long-term growth we will uh put
it into a growth and maturation media
which will allow these uh organizers to
grow for upsells for several weeks or
even up to months
at a time
here we have some images which are found
in the application note of what the uh
the the cell should look like at
different stages so after the
cells are the first picture is after the
cells are placed in the low attachment
plates uh they're uh they're forming the
cell aggregate as you see in the middle
and this is before the induction so you
start seeing the cells aggregate forming
a nice pfc spheroid uh the middle
picture here is that day seven after
they've been in induction media for a
bit you could see sort of a denseness
starting in the middle with the fine
border on the outside showing that the
uh the cells are primed to go down that
neural pathway
the last picture here is uh after the
the parenting the encapsulation this is
more in the long term growth phase you
you are really seeing the uh the the
development of the neural organizer with
these nice convoluted epithelial
structures on the outside of these nice
ruffles as well as the uh the densest uh
in the middle showing the proper uh the
organization of the orbit
here's some immunofluorescence pictures
uh highlighting uh different aspects
such as
sox1 neural stem cells here shown
in the pink as well as the neurons that
are radiating from the outside uh here
on the left as shown in green so
these images highlight that
after in this case 47 days different
types of cell types that are present
through our imaging platforms
uh what i want to highlight here is uh
through our gene expression analysis is
that with this method it really relies
just on the aggregation of the cells and
and the media that we use uh to form our
uh these uh these neural organoids
without having to add in any type of
special small molecules or growth
factors to guide it down
uh to have it
produce a region specific part of the
brain it's really more of a mini brain
sort of a whole brain snapshot of early
developed brain and the gene expression
the gene expression analysis highlights
when we probe for different cell markers
you could see on the right that there's
evidence of different cell types from
different areas of the brain so uh
highlighting here on the right we'll see
different types of neurons evidence of
forebrain neural ectoderm
the different and also some areas of
cerebral cortex and hippocampus so it's
really a nice i think a broad snapshot
of what we'd see in an early development
whole brain um utilizing this method so
i think this is a good
this gene analysis kind of shows the
range of cell types that are present
following this method
switching gears from neural organizer
the next workflow i want to talk about
is our cancer spheroid applications our
r d team in
in bangalore
really worked hard to
develop these protocols for generating
cancer spheroids with these eight
different cancer cell lines
utilizing 3d models
for cancer research i think is ideal
because you get a you get the proper uh
morphology to mimic the tumor micro
environment and help you understand more
so how uh drugs can penetrate or
possibly start developing resistance in
a in vitro system so uh the teamwork too
for optimizing the protocols for
developing spheroids uh look at looked
at ways for optimizing the cell culture
times and conditions did some
characterization as well as apply them
to different high tube athletes there's
just a lot of great work from our
bangalore team
so if you click on one of the um
the protocols in this case the t47d uh
cancer cell line this is what you would
you would see you'd see a nice uh
detailed page first starting on how to
maintain the cells in this 2d culture
before forming spheroids
uh mir a list of the materials that are
required with hyperlinks to products
that we uh that we offer at thermo
fisher a nice detailed protocol on uh on
cell harvesting how to plate them uh
putting them into the into the nunclon
sphere plates and also tips and tricks
on uh
on recommended cell densities and
development times which are catered to
each
cell type so
each of these protocols will have
different parameters based on the cell
type that's being analyzed
i think a big help here are some of the
images that are shown here such as this
graph here which highlights different
cell densities that we use to form these
periods but also looking them at
different days or lengths that they're
in culture so this is a nice visual qc
of what your spheroids should look like
over time uh it's going to make sure
that you know that they're forming
properly i think it's a uh it's a good
way to make sure that you're you're
following the product correctly and uh
it's setting it just gives you a nice
view of what that's your
your on your protocol and these were our
brightfield images taken with our evos
microscope
further characterization that was done
over some viability uh
assays such as our presta blue viability
uh for these steroids shown here at day
six as you can see uh at six days with
increasing cell density that's what you
would expect you
you'd wanna see uh more um that higher
cell viability which is indicative by
the graph
while this asset i think shows relative
um
viability doesn't give you a sense of
the number of dead cells that that are
present
so uh to assess uh more detail of the
viability they performed live dead uh
cell assays to highlight the number of
uh live cells which are highlighted in
green but also the presence of uh
necrotic cells or dead cells that are
that form in the middle that you'll see
with increasing cell density so i think
that these images kind of give you a
nice along with the uh the bryce of them
just kind of give you an idea of what
the
cell should look like but also the
relative health of the cells based on
your length and culture and also your
steaming density so it gives you some
options depending on your experimental
parameters of how long you should um you
should have your protocol run for
the next uh foreflow i want to highlight
here is our hepatic spheroids which can
be used for looking at metabolic assays
what's next about our this
the hepatic steroids is that
the last the first two um
applications i talked about are
comprised of a bunch of parts that that
you you put together to
create that workflow this is actually
the first uh one of our first the 3d
product which is actually sold as as a
kit itself so under one catalog number
it provides you all the materials that
you need to form this model
utilizing uh package furious versus 2d
has i think definite advantages
your cells are in culture longer and
going from
just
days to a matter of weeks higher level
of sip activity to measure drug response
but also better gene and protein
expression so within the kit it has
everything that you need to create your
model uh your cell source the primary
hepatocytes the place to create the
sphere is the nucleon spheroplates as
well as the media required for growth
and development and the images here on
the right highlight what the spheroid
should look like following the protocol
as well as the
increased sip activity uh comparing 2d
to 3d you can see the advantages of 3d
if you carry it out to three weeks you
have the same amount of stiff activity
as you would see in 2d after only five
days so you're really lengthening your
your window being able to use these uh
the cell model
this slide here really highlights the
simplicity of the
let's say you start your expert you do
the you start thinking on monday you
start by fine counting and plating your
cells and you place them in the number
one sphere
uh ultraviolet attachment plate to form
the spheroids uh put them in the
incubator you don't have to touch them
until friday where you just you do
immediate change and let them go over
the weekend and then on monday you could
start your uh your uh your different
assays you want on the on the forms here
right so really i think it's a very
simple setting and forget it workflow
which allows you to get in about seven
days workable actuaries to look at drug
metabolism
the last workflow i want to highlight is
our
utilizing a another plastics product or
nail cell cluster inserts and carrier
plate systems to develop 3d human skin a
little bit on the um
the
the cell culture inserts here is that we
um
is that they are us
they come in three different well
formats 6 12 and 24 they have the
insert is a polycarbonate semi-parallel
membrane of different pore sizes uh
which
in the uniqueness of that is it has an
adjustable height feature which allows
you to place the insert at different
heights within the well which is
highlighted here in the image below
the carrier plate function is is nice
because
for the multi insert
plates
you're able to take all the uh
wells out all at once and you and you're
able to exchange media or or collect
media easier because you can take all
the inserts out all at once and these uh
plates can be used for different aspects
transport co-culture
uh invasion as well as well as
chemotaxis athletes so they're very
useful uh plates
so
uh this uh
the skin mass system has an application
though which walk through a little bit
the protocol you generated you start by
just by coding the insert with some
protein coding matrix and ecm
for about 30 minutes then you're going
to see
adult carotenocytes on top and let them
sit submerged
as with the cells under the uh
submerged underneath the level of the
media for two days to let the cells set
onto the insert
after two days you're going to bring the
media level down to the air liquid
interface or ali level which will then
which which is when you put the media
just at the bottom
to the level of the insert bottom so the
bottom of the cells will be in contact
with the media but the cells on top will
be exposed to air allowing the
keratinocytes to stratify and
differentiate into the different layer
uh two different
layers of skin that you would see
uh you let that go for 12 days feeding
accordingly and then allow for your cell
health and characterization to be formed
after that
so i think
to you what's great about the
interesting is the adjustable height
feature and in this protocol which that
is just what high feature comes to play
and allows you to have flexibility in
terms of your feeding schedule for
example if you were to place the
um
the insert on the high level which would
be the level here on the far left of the
of the graph
you to get to ali you would need 1.5
mils of media in the well
but if you have at the height you have
more media in
in the well you don't have to do any
type of feed for four days so you can
adjust the level of when you have to uh
do any type of cell maintenance based on
the height
of the insert uh that you play you place
it within the carrier plate so allow you
some flexibility in terms of how you uh
you
you do your protocol
allow you to maybe not have to come in
on a weekend or during a busy time uh
because of this the adjustable height
feature
and
this this picture is shown in the app
note here we have uh
as you can see uh if you take a cross
section of the skin
you can see the different layers of uh
different skin layers that have been
differentiated and you could probe for
these by looking at immunofluorescence
or histochemistry or gene expression for
these different types of cell markers
the cytokeratins laura crane or in
blueprint just to show different ways of
highlighting the different layers that
have been that have been produced
uh you could also look at cell health by
looking at live dead cell stains and
these could be uh these all could be
image utilizing our our our evos imaging
systems or gene expression to our quant
studio real-time pcr systems
finally if we go in
looking at some resources that we have
for 3d if you go to our website
thermofisher.com 3d models
we can
the website here can kind of guide you
along your 3d cell culture journey here
we have many key protocols and methods
and relevant products made which i've
highlighted here in this talk the
application notes for the different
workflows that we talked about are
can be found here
we have scientific posters that are
available kind of showing the latest and
greatest which is going on in our r d
group another way of showing our other
which highlight our products in action
and are also also been presented at
different scientific conferences
around the globe
uh with other uh educational resources
such as our 3d cell culture handbook a
very comprehensive handbook on
different culturing techniques uh
methodology uh characterization
instrumentation i think it
it's a good resource for either the
beginner who's looking to transition
from 2d to 3d or the other person that's
more experienced which is know they've
known how to create a model is looking
for different ways to improve on what
they've already used
there are digital training and
e-learning courses that are available
such as
how to create neural organoids
getting started in 3d cell culture and
one that we just produced earlier this
year is on 3d cell culture and analysis
so kind of walking through
the training is going to walk through
different parts of the 3d cell culture
workflow
and finally we also have the molecular
probes handbook which goes into all the
different fluorescent labeling
technologies uh to highlight uh the
cells
which can be a key aspect when you're
trying to develop your 3d model being
able to image and analyze uh your your
complex model
so finally in summary i hope being able
to convey that 3d cell culture models
better recapitulate the in vivo
environment but in an in vitro way
here at thermofish we can support the
entire 3d cell model workflow going from
model creation to characterization and
as well as to imaging and analysis
with optimized protocols for different
workflows such as neural organoids 3d
skin cancer spheroid as well as hepatic
spheroids
and finally visit our website at
thermofisher.com
3d models for useful information how to
create and analyze your desired 3d model
thank you
thank you edwin for the insightful
session on 3d model workflow and
applications i am sure that your
audience will be interested to visit the
educational resources online for more
information
next i would like to invite bhaskar to
share more about the essential tools for
labeling and detection in 3d models
thanks edwin for a great introduction on
how to grow spheroids and then all the
complexities and
tricks to grow
both steroids and organics with
different models
so today my my name is bhaskar
mandeville i'm a senior r d manager in
uh molecular probes division of the
thermo fisher scientific
i'm involved where i manage a team
involved in developing fluorescent
reagents that are that can be used to
measure lot of different functions
in both monolayer cells and 3d spheroids
and also tissues
so when a
edwin already touched upon the cell
culture part i'm not going to talk too
much about that but when you look at the
steps to label in detection of 3d models
it is similar to what we do with 2d
models
the only difference is more complexity
with the 3d models
in terms of staining and also analyzing
the samples
so the step one i'd been already talked
about and step two is about labeling and
optimization which i am going to give
you a few examples in today's seminar
and then step three is in imaging
analysis and i'm going to talk to you
about
two different platforms using a white
field microscope to just check
the steroids and the staining part and
then using a little bit higher end
microscope after that like confocal
microscope or cx7 high content imaging
platforms
so when you
look at
labeling and optimization
molecular probes has
we have about three different strategies
in this space one is conjugated
antibodies both you can conjugate
primary antibodies using our conjugation
kits but also we have several uh
alexa floor based
conjugated iggs that can be used as
secondary antibodies to stain your
samples or stain your markers
and then we have fluorescent proteins
based on baculovirus system
where you can
mark
your cells when you are growing
spheroids for example if you are growing
heterogeneous cell populations in
steroids or organoids you can mark them
using either gfp or rfp using our bacmen
based fluorescent proteins and these are
very useful for both
lived live or fixed samples because
these are retained even after
fixing the samples
so
you can look at the demarcation of
different populations within the
spheroid or organoid after fixing your
samples
and also after staining with your
antibodies of interest as well
and then we have organic fluorophores
which are small molecules
and these are mostly used in live cells
like spheroids or organized and also
some of these probes can be used in
fixed samples as well and you can also
fix after staining the spheroids or
organoids
so when we talk about
labeling and optimization
there are some minor differences between
when you use td monolayer protocols
compared to the 3d samples
most of the times
you use the same concentration of the
dye
that you use for 2d
monolayer cells
but the
most of the differences come when you
are
doing the treatment with the drugs or
staining time
that incubation time when we are it also
depends on each
fluorophore some fluorophores are more
much better in in
diffusing into the
unstaining interior into the spheroid or
argonide while some take more time it
depends on what die you are using and
what function you are measuring
and also
it creates it is more a little bit more
complicated when we are trying to do
antibody staining because they are a
little bit bigger molecules
so you may have to use
more tricks to get the antibody into the
interior of the spheroid or organoid
so when you are talking about a cell
health continuum either in a tissue or a
3d organized sample
we are talking about
when we are measuring we are talking
about
looking at healthy cells what the
phenotype looks like and also look
looking at
stressed populations
and apoptotic cells and
dead cells
and also some sometimes inflammatory
response when you are talking about
especially tissue or steroids or
organoids
after the
dead cell of the of some of the dead
cells are dying in the population
yeah when we are talking about cell
health continuum as you can see here for
each
state of the cell
in the population you can measure
different parameters for example for a
healthy cell you can look at
mitochondrial membrane potential you can
look at the cell proliferation
as we all know that there is a doubling
time of each kind of cell lines and also
you can look at morphology which is
mostly intact in a healthy cell so when
the cells are stressed out either due to
tissue environment or due to
drug treatment that you do
into the cells
the stress can be either
undergo recovery into the healthy cell
or it can
go to the other side where the cells are
dying due to apoptosis or necrosis which
can be measured by
either caspase activation dna damage or
loss of membrane permeability in the
cells
and also as i talked to you before after
the cells are dying there is
inflammatory response or phagocytosis
that happens in the tissue environment
and also in steroids and organoids
so now i'm going to talk about a little
bit about mitochondrial depolarization
and oxidative stress measurements as a
result of stress
here is an example where this is a
monolayer population just i want to talk
about
how these reagents work
here is an example where we used tmrm
which measures mitochondrial membrane
potential which is high in healthy cells
there is more staining in healthy cells
and then
we have we measure hypoptosis using
oxidative stress using cell rocks green
reagent which is a fluorogenic reagent
to measure oxidative stress in cells
which it is dark in healthy cells when
there is not much oxidative stress and
when you treat the drugs with an oxidant
you can see increase in
staining of cell rocks green reagent
and decrease in tmrm mitochondrial
membrane potential indicator which says
that as you
with time after uh treating with the
drug there is reduction in mitochondrial
membrane potential as the cells are
stressed out and increase in oxidative
stress within the cells
these are u2 cells stained with 50
micromolar menadion
and here is another another example
where you can measure these
two
phenomena or
markers
in a spheroid sample here is an example
where we did it on confocal microscope
this is a
a549
3d spheroid models where we stained with
nuke blue live teddy probes reagent and
then mito tracker orange which again
like tmr measures mitochondrial membrane
potential and then cell rocks deplete
reagent this is a healthy steroid this
is not a treated spheroid this is an
example just to show that you can
measure across the z in a spheroid using
confocal microscope as you can see here
you can
count the cells using nuke blue live
rediprops reagent and then you can also
look at the mito tracker staining an
entire spheroid
which shows the healthy cells and there
are some sparsely populated cells which
that stain for cell rocks deep red
reagents cell rocks temperature agent
similar to
cell rock's green reagent measures
oxidative stress in cells but in a
different spectral
profile
and when you when it comes to staining
both this mito tracker
orange and new blue live reagents are
very good in penetrating the spheroids
and we do it for 30 minutes and when it
comes to cell rocks deep red reagent it
is not as permanent in the spheroid so
we
use a little bit more like a two hour
staining for this cell rocks deep red
reagent to penetrate into the spheroid
and stain all the cells in the spheroid
so next one in the cell health continuum
is measuring apoptosis and dna damage
which is uh once the cells pass through
the stress response and they can no
longer recover and they are dying you
can measure those using again tmr
mitochondrial membrane potential
indicator and
sullivant caspase 3x7 substrate which is
cleaved in only in apoptotic cells you
don't see much staining in healthy cells
again as you can see this is a
population of hela cells
monolayer cells where there is tree
where we did treat treatment for six
hours using 500 nanomolar sterosporine
as you can see
over time there is decrease in
mitochondrial membrane potential as seen
by decrease in tmrm staining and
increase in sullivan staining
to mark the apoptotic cells in the
population
again here the staining with the these
reagents both tmrm and sullivan gasps
reagents are very penetrant into the
steroids so
i will show you the next one's spheroid
population here's an example where we
stained a549 cells after treating them
with different dosage doses of
nucleosomine
which is a drug that induces apoptosis
and also causes depolarization of
mitochondrial membrane potential
here the the rows show
the
multiples the energy here the n is equal
to six and then the columns show
increasing concentrations of nucleosome
drug as we increase the
concentration of the nucleosomine as you
can see in this
left side in the image
you can see that there is decrease in
mitochondrial membrane potential and
increase in apoptotic cells
and this can be easily quantitated using
our cell inside cx7
laser illumination based high content
screening platform you can measure the
number of cells that
stain with mitochondrial membrane
potential
and
also stay in the popular and then
quantitate the populations that stain
with sullivant
gas phase reagent as well to mark the
apoptotic cells in the spheroids as you
can see here with increasing
concentration of nicolasamide
you can see decrease in population that
stain with mitotracker
orange which
says that the with increasing
concentration nucleosimide it's the
cells are losing mitochondrial membrane
potential and there are more apoptotic
cells as seen by staining with
the caspase-3 is a 3x7 reagent
here's an another example where we
show
the attack as a st
t cells attacking a spheroid and killing
the cells in a
skbr3 spheroid
and then again again here the cell death
can be seen by sullivan caspase 3x7
reagent
while the t cells are stained with
deeper cell tracker deep red because
these are
stained separately the staining is for
30 minutes with the cell tracker
temperature agent while in spheroids
we stain after the t cell penetration
for 24 hours we stain it with sullivan
caspase 3x7
green reagent for about 30 minutes
and this is an example where
spheroids
are stained with a hypoxia reagent this
hypoxia reagent gets
fluorescent
only when the
percentage of oxygen goes down below
five percent
in cells as you can see here there are
some cells which have brighter staining
compared to other cells based on the
level of hypoxia in the cells
and again i want to
[Music]
point out that
there is not like a very good gradient
of hypoxia in spheroids as compared to a
cancer tissue
because there are no blood vessels in
the spheroids right so
it depends on more like diffusion of co2
and oxygen into this spheroid rather
than a very perfect gradient that you
usually see in a cancer tissue
and
the next set of reagent that i am going
to talk about
is the reagent that measures the plasma
membrane integrity in the dead cells
this can be both necrotic cells are late
apoptotic cells
as we know that
during apoptosis it undergoes dna damage
nuclear condensation
and
caspase activation
that are earlier parameters but in the
end these cells lose plasma membrane
permeability as well and then
they dissociate and then engulf during
phagocytosis process
and then there is also another way of
cell death which is necrosis
which is more drastic and leads to loss
of plasma membrane integrity leading to
cell death
here's an example where there is
antibody mediated cytotoxicity these are
skb r3
spheroids as you can see here where the
natural killer cells are added to the
skb r3 spheroids and then the nk cells
are stained with as described their cell
trace violet reagent for 30 minutes
washed the reagent off and then added to
the spheroids
left over six hours
and then
we measure dead cells using live dead
kit and the green staining is calcium
which signifies the
live cells and then as you can see the
red dead dead cells are stained with
homodymer stain that comes with the live
dead cell imaging kit as you can see the
dead cells are marked with the red
staining in these spheroids this is a
again a
earlier time point in the
treatment with nk cells you don't see
many dead cells in this steroids
teaser here is an example where
we have
grown zero a549 spheroids
and then uh added nk cells with or
without situx map drug citrix map drug
is a egf anti-age egfr drug
which
actually
kills the
cancer cells
by inhibiting the proliferation of
specific cancer cells as you can see
here
minus and uh acetoximab and minus nk
cells you see a little bit of apoptotic
cell population and when you add nk
cells within in six hours you can you
see a little bit more increase in
apoptotic cell population as measured by
sullivant caspase reagent and then when
you add both cetuximab and nk cells
there is potentiation of killing of
cells mediated through nk cells and you
can see
increase in
apoptotic cell population within the
spheroid
and you can also see here the nk cells
penetrating the spheroid and killing the
cells by apoptosis as well
here using our cell insight cx7 laser
eye content screening platform
you can see you can actually quantitate
these apoptotic cell populations very
easily
and as you can see here
sure as shown in the previous slide you
can see increase in apoptotic cell
population
as we go from no nk cells to plus nk
cells and also when we use antibody
pleasant cases there is even more
increase in apoptotic cell population
as measured by
caspase reagent
again the last step in
labeling and detection is using
our microscopes and then other some
other tricks to
efficiently measure these
steroids
here is an example using a white field
microscope you when you use a wide field
microscope the
light is dispersed so you don't see very
clear delineation of cells especially
when you use thick tissue samples or
steroids or organoids
and when you use a confocal microscope
as you can see here there is more
pointed uh
illumination of light
of the sample so you see more clear
delineation as you can see from a
previous slide where there is white
field microscopy here using confocal
microscope you can see more clear
delineation of the
staining in spheroid sample this is an
example of hepatocyte spheroid measured
on our
cell inside cx7 laser system
using laser illumination
and also another way of improving
your resolution within the spheroid or
argonide is clearing reagent so because
most of the times we use
the media or pbs
in this spheroid or arginoid sample so
there is some
differences in refractive index between
the objective of the microscope that you
use
and the sample which is in aqueous phase
so to reduce to match a little bit more
of the refractive index between the
object to end your sample you can use
one of our cytovista clearing reagents
this is basically diffusing into the
sample
and
matching the refractive index so there
is
more penetration of light and then more
resolution into the spheroid sample
as you can see here after clearing with
cytovista clearing reagent you can see
you can measure you can see more cells
and also you can measure more
quantitate more cells within the
spheroid
here is another example where
the spheroids of different sizes are
grown as you can see here these steroid
size can
go anywhere from 50 microns to about 300
microns with increasing number of cells
when you grow spheroids and they were
stained with cytox green
a nuclear dye and then
as you can see before clearing
has increased the size of the steroid
you cannot count all the cells within
the spheroid and after clearing you can
see there is increasingly clear
delineation of the cells and also you
can count those cells using uh
high content imaging systems
so you can use our eos m7000 imaging
system in automated way both in 384 well
plates and 96 well plates this is a way
of
looking at your spheroids quickly
looking at your spheroids and also your
staining patterns using this but again
as explained before this is a wide field
imaging system so you don't
get clear delineation of sample
within the spheroid so this is just for
checking your sample
and as you can see here you can look at
the all the steroids and this is a 384
will plate scanned
it takes about three to four minutes to
scan through the quick do a quick scan
and look at okay there are spheroids in
all the wells and they're looking good
so so you you go to the next step
of going to a much higher end
high content screening platform which
has a laser illumination and also
confocal microscopy system
and also it comes with a smart scanning
we can we call it eureka scan
where you can quickly scan through a
plate
and delineate your spheroids
because when you especially when you are
growing in a 96 cell plate or 384 plate
the spheroids can be at different places
within the 96 well so
using a smart scan or urea cascan will
allow you to quickly scan at lower
magnification and identify your
spheroids and when you go to higher
magnifications in the second round you
can actually just go to the spheroids
and then
image them instead of going through all
the fields which takes about a lot of
time
here's an example where you identify
the
using the hook staining you identify
here you can use even bright field
or
staining at a lower magnification you
can use 2x or 4x quickly scan through
the plate and then you go to on the
bottom panel you can see you can go to
higher magnification like 20x or
even higher magnifications and then just
go to the sample and scan through it
here is an exa as an example of
identifying a sample at lower
magnification and going there to the
particular fields it will save a lot of
time
if you don't use eureka scan it take it
may take up to four to five three to
four hours to scan through a 96 well
plate
and then when you use ureka scan as you
can see here it takes about 28 minutes
24 seconds to go through a 96 cell plate
because
both the
first round of scanning and second draft
of scanning because you don't have to
scan through the entire
field of view you just go through the
specific fields that have steroids and
then you scan through at higher
magnifications
so
i will stop here and then thank you for
your attention and i am
ready to take questions if you have any
thank you so much basker and edwin for
sharing your expert insights in to these
topics
we'll now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
we will do our best to address as many
questions as possible
in the event that we are unable to do so
representatives from thermo fisher
scientific will reach out via email with
an answer
it looks like we have got a few
questions already coming in
perhaps can we we can get started with
questions for edwin
so
the first question for edwin is
can you summarize the difference between
gel tracks matrix and other ecm
and what kind of organoid culture
applications would you recommend for the
use of gel tricks
yeah thank you that's a great question
gelffrex is
one type what we call a naturally
derived ecm which is a
in this case they reduce growth factor
based membrane extract that comes from a
mouse tumor
within this matrix it has you know the
different types of components uh
collagens lamins and tactins and other
the components that comprise this uh
this extracellular matrix it also helps
the gelatrix also helps form organized
scaffold to provide structural support
for your tissue as well as offer
functional input that will help modulate
cellular function helps with cellular
cell communication and growth and
development
gel tricks also is a being one of the
natural ones is also a temperature
controlled material uh which in this
case is when you warm it up it'll
actually uh polymerize to create the
salt uh the solid material so
as a naturally you see on the other
examples of this uh would be collagen
laminate and gelatin
uh other types of ecms that are
available are synthetic ecms which
actually rely on synthetic polymers to
to uh to create the stiffness so by look
if you look at the physical biological
mechanical properties of these scaffolds
you can tune them independently by
changing molecular weight cross-linker
and using a different type of way to
polymerize so
what's nice about the synthetic one is
you have control over how stiff you make
your extracellular matrix also uh how to
time when it happens and examples of the
of different types of synthetic matrices
are polyethylene glycol as well as
polyglycolic acid based uh ecm
the second part of the question
for what kind of applications would you
recommend for gel tracks i'd say you can
use gel tricks for different ipsc
derived organic models such as neural
organized which i highlighted here
patient drug and also patient-drive
organic models such as intestine or
cancer-derived patient-sample organoids
they can also be used to develop spheric
models
by adding them in with the cells to help
the cells aggregate and form nice
compact spheroids which is highlighted
in the cancer story protocols that we
discussed
okay thank you
next question
what are the pros and cons of using low
cell attachment plates versus
non-treated polystyrene plates for the
3d spheroid culture what are some key
considerations to help me a researcher
decide between the two options
yeah another great question
both of these types of plates have been
used to generate spheroids with the
non-treated one uh polystyrene ones i
think it's more of an older method
the nitrite plates will serve them while
they have a hydrophobic surface
similarly you see with a low
ultra low coated attachment plate uh
this the the non treated plates are
mainly just for cells growing in
suspensions that actually do not really
need that at the end point is not to
actually have to have that great but
just rather not have them attached to
the surface uh again uh this is an older
method where and they were used early on
when i guess the spirit forming uh
methods were used such as the uh the the
hanging drop method
but for easier and more consistent cell
aggregation or to create 3d models i
recommend those low attachment plates
such as our non-coated spherical plates
since you're trying to skip the cells to
aggregate rather than not laid down as a
monolayer
the these low attachment plates are the
way to go they promote uniform
cell aggregation to generate
reproducible steroids and many many
values minimizing that variability in a
developing 3d model is key uh as
as
the ola plates are designed for that
type of that formation
hey thank you
um
the last question for edwin can you
share more about the kind of controls
you have in place
or parameters you are measuring to
ensure the reproducibility
of the neural organoids generated in the
lab
yeah uh yeah i think this question has
been asked in the field as well too i
think in general you know i think i'd
recommend that
uh depending on the model you develop
some general qc parameters to help with
those types of consistency issues
like for example looking at the
size of the model appearance like gross
morphology through
through immunohistochemistry or
fluorescent standing to look at spatial
organization
another thing you can look at is doing a
small qpcr panel to make sure that the
cells are differentiating proceeding
into the new cell types that should be
forming over time so just little ways to
make sure that the model is progressing
in different ways
specifically say for the neural
organoids that we're talking about here
certain things that you would look for
would be epithelial outgrowth during the
expansion phase so you want to look for
an increase in size and to change
morphology and this stuff should occur
perhaps i mean at the same time if you
were to do this experiment several times
uh the timing of these changes should
happen uh at the at the exact uh timing
uh to make sure that the organoid is
developing properly so those are things
that i would that i'd recommend but also
depending on the model you're generating
whether it's whole brain or region
specific uh some of these
recommendations uh you know maybe have
to be tailored to that model so a
specific recommendations may be
difficult to make but so just a couple
of things that i would that i would
suggest
great thank you
thank you edwin for answering these
questions
and now we'll proceed with questions for
basker
the first question is i would like to
confocal image my steroids with minimal
distortion to their 3d structure
and with as little sample drift as
possible
can this be achieved with glass bottom
microplate microplate or microwell if so
what are some tips and tricks to get
good images for analysis
here's especially use confocal
microscope
uh yeah so that uh that i like to
confocal image my steroids with minimal
distortion
yeah when we
yeah it is a great question and then
when we try to
image this unconfocal microscope
yeah i would suggest you use as much as
15 thin glass bottom plates
to image these and there is always some
drift because when we are especially
when we are putting it in the media
i would suggest that you
either use a clearing reagent which puts
the sample
in a place or
probably mount it in one of our
prolonged gold mountains
which
will help you to keep in a
at one place so that there is not much
drift when you are actually especially
doing the
z-sectioning of the spheroids or
organoids
and uh
yeah that should help with the
drift
and if it is a fixed sample usually
you don't see too much drift you can
actually do without mounting and then
there is always like you can use other
methods of clearing to
reduce the defra diffraction of the
light so that you can get more
penetration into the sample but
otherwise it should be fine
thank you um and our last question
uh for basker for researchers beginning
their journey in 3d steroid culture
can you advise on the types of
microscopes and additional technologies
that will be needed versus 2d to observe
their 3d cultures
yeah in my experience you you don't need
like entirely different setup for three
days steroids but the only thing
is some there are some minor differences
like using
you bottom plates
for growing spheroids and sometimes you
may have to use ecm and gel tricks and
other methods to grow spheroids or
argonides
when it comes to
imaging itself if you have a confocal
microscope or a wide field microscope in
the lab
that should cater to your needs but if
you want to do quantitation probably you
may need something like our
cell insight cx7 imaging system
where you have both wide field and
confocal microscopy in there so that you
can
not only image but also quantitate your
sample very efficiently on the fly
all right thank you basker for your
replies and to our audience
i hope the sharing has been helpful to
your current research work and future
plans
this wraps up our giftco galaxy tour
webinar on developing better techniques
for 3d culture and analysis
once again i would like to thank edwin
ambassador for sharing with us their
knowledge application notes and
essential tools for developing and
analyzing 3d cell models
that could enable better understanding
of complex biology in a physiologically
relevant context
a big thank you to our audience for
joining us today and submitting
interesting questions
for those questions that we are unable
to answer live we will follow up with an
answer via email
we hope all of you have gained more
knowledge today that will help you to
enhance your lab skills
we would also like to thank lab roots
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
thank you and stay tuned
to more educational webinars from thermo
fisher scientific